so in our last video we started looking
at this speech by franklin delano
roosevelt which he gave at his
inauguration in march of 1933. and we
took some time to just identify what was
happening in this speech and also the
context of this speech coming at the
height of the great depression so now
we're going to dive deeper into our
textual analysis
and explore the source figure out what
is going on with roosevelt's language
and what he's trying to say and what his
biases are so
let's get a little more into what else
goes on in this speech not just the very
famous opening paragraph so we start
here with saying uh people are facing
the grim problem of existence and a
foolish optimist can deny the dark
realities of the moment
and then what comes next well so let's
let's hear all of this in context so um
yet our distress comes from no failure
of substance we are stricken by no
plague of locusts compared with the
perils which our forefathers conquered
because they believed and were not
afraid we still have much to be thankful
for nature still offers her bounty and
human efforts have multiplied it plenty
is at our doorstep but a generous use of
it languishes in the very site of the
supply primarily this is because the
rulers of the exchange of mankind's
goods have failed through their own
stubbornness and their own incompetence
have admitted their failure and
abdicated practices of the unscrupulous
money changers stand indicted in the
court of public opinion rejected by the
hearts and minds of men
restoration calls however not for
changes in ethics alone this nation asks
for action and action now what's
interesting about this paragraph is that
there's a lot of bible stuff going on in
here um there's a lot of biblical
references uh that serve to do i think a
lot of work uh for roosevelt uh in this
inaugural address as you talked i just
underlined the things that really stood
out to me as maybe kind of the heart of
what he was saying and you're saying
these are like biblical references so
what do you mean by that some some of
them are so when we're talking about
plague of locusts and money changers
specifically
we're looking at old and new testament
references respectively in fact later in
the speech he refers to money changers
being chased out of our nation's temple
which is a deliberate reference to the
new testament okay so
this is this is very grand we love to
hear this speech so much because it has
that kind of ringing of authenticity in
in a way that maybe a modern speech does
not well some of that authenticity comes
through association with
epic literature and the bible so he's
making these allusions to great biblical
events right like the plague of locusts
being visited upon egypt which was like
a great and terrible plague and he's
using that as a counterpoint to
the misery of the present moment he's
saying look things could be worse
we could be ancient egypt in the bible
and locusts could be eating all of our
crops things are bad
but it's not like god himself is willing
destruction upon us okay yeah i i think
this is also another one of the really
interesting things about the great
depression i mean it's true that there
were farm failures during the dust bowl
but on the whole it's not like people
stopped producing food this wasn't a
famine what it was was a crisis of
confidence where prices went down
significantly and so farmers could not
make a living on their crops it's not
that they didn't have food it's that
they didn't have money right i also feel
like there's a different aspect to the
reason that he uses this biblical
language here and i think that's because
it's very authoritative right when you
stand up in front of a group of people
and you know roosevelt has this powerful
voice
which really resonates with people and
you speak like a preacher would speak it
says this is a man of authority this is
a man who perhaps is in touch with the
moral authority associated with the
christian bible sure i mean for the for
a very long time authority was kind of
correlated with your ability to quote
chapter and verse i mean we're talking
about a man who has just put his hand on
a bible in order to swear himself in
so it really makes him seem not only
like he knows what he's talking about
but also that he's got a handle on the
situation
so so what we're saying is that by by
harnessing this language he's trying to
harness the authority that people have
invested in the church by using the
language of the church so what we're
doing here i might call step three which
is
to identify
how an argument is made right
so
we're looking at his rhetorical
strategies
uh and seeing how they're effective or
in perhaps another case not effective in
conveying his opinion and i say opinion
at this point what would we say that his
opinion of the great depression is
that it's specific people's fault uh
that it is at the fault of not just this
wave of panic but um on account of some
greedy people the unscrupulous money
changers
and the rulers of the exchanges so he's
blaming bankers for the great depression
which i think is is fair i mean there's
very little regulation in the 1920s that
would prevent the kind of fraud that
could lead to a collapse of banking for
example
insider trading is not illegal or
and most people bought stocks on margin
which is a terrible idea which means you
only have to put 10 percent of the value
of a bond down before you buy it which
means that there's a lot of theoretical
money floating around out there that's
not backed by much real money oh that
sounds like a terrible idea it was a
terrible so it's like buying it's like
like buying stocks on credit exactly oh
man
his argument is that first things could
be worse second of all the reason things
are bad is because of these people thing
number three here's how we're going to
get back on track all right so this is
where we get here at the end so the
nation asks for action and action now
which i'd say is a you know not only a
mention of how he's going to get things
done but a
covert poke at herbert hoover for not
doing much
and then he says our greatest primary
task is to put people to work remember
there's an unemployment rate of 25
percent that is so many people our
current unemployment rate is less than
five percent to give you an idea
this is no unsolvable problem if we face
it wisely and courageously it can be
accomplished in part by direct
recruiting by the government itself
trading the task as we retreat the
emergency of a war
but at the same time through this
employment accomplishing greatly needed
projects to stimulate and reorganize the
use of our natural resources this is a
radical idea it is a really radical idea
and this is one reason why historians
love to study the great depression and
the
administration of franklin delano
roosevelt because this is kind of the
decade where we threw out the rule book
and i think what roosevelt is saying
here is that he was willing to try
anything to conquer the great depression
and one of the things he tries is
bringing the government into the process
of giving people work
okay so we've got a sense of what he's
arguing and how he's arguing it
but let's take a a higher level look now
so i would say step four is seeing if
you can
analyze
the potential bias of a source
and i want to be clear
that
all sources are biased
i think
a common misconception is that
if you're looking at a source it's
either biased or it's not right it's
written by someone who has an agenda or
someone who is completely impartial and
that is never the case what about a
photograph if i take a photograph of
something or someone isn't that an
objective rendering of that person or
object well it certainly shows what was
there at that moment in time but even
photographers are making choices right
when you pick up a camera and you take a
picture of a thing you are taking a
picture of that thing and not something
else which is in itself a form of bias
to say i think this is important or this
is what i want you to see
so where we put the frame is a choice
yes so so the question is what is
roosevelt not saying in this speech
what is he not taking a photograph of
what's just outside the view of his
camera and why is he taking this
photograph of a speech right when he sat
down to write this what was motivating
him and what are some of the perhaps
even
less obvious factors about
why he makes the argument that he does
well i mean obviously the man has a bias
in favor of his own politics i mean
these are his administration's ideas
right so he's going to be coming out in
favor of of those very strongly
so fdr
is a democrat
and there really haven't been many
democrats in office since before the
lincoln administration sure the 1860s so
that's a new thing i mean this is the
popular base rejecting hoover and the
republican party because of the great
depression right
so he's bringing democratic political
ideas to the table here so he's trying
to make a case for those political
ideals in this speech he was elected by
a majority of american voters but now he
has to make the case to the rest of the
united states he has to make a case to
the people that didn't elect him
right and so he's saying
that direct recruiting by the government
itself
government jobs having the powers as if
the depression were war that is a case
for really strong government
intervention which is a keystone of the
democratic party compared to republicans
who generally advocate for a smaller
government
so he's saying this is what's going to
work the democratic platform of using
the government in the economy and in
social programs is what's going to work
to get us out of this depression so he's
making like a big strong case for
federalism exactly what i think is
interesting though here is that there's
a lot he doesn't say and i think that's
also important to look at when you're
analyzing a primary source there's a lot
that you could talk about but you make
choices about what to talk about and
what not to mention so what could you
say he doesn't mention here he doesn't
mention
how any of this is going to work
yeah i think that's maybe the biggest
missing piece here right i mean this is
this is broad strokes this is getting
people on board but nowhere does he say
okay here's exactly what i'm going to do
let me tell you how many dollars i'm
going to spend how many people i'm going
to hire what sort of cabinets i'm going
to create this is not a time for
specifics she says this is almost more
of an inspirational speech to say okay i
gotcha all right so
we've
looked at the source we've kind of
analyzed its rhetorical strategies and
its potential bias so the last thing we
might want to do with this is now think
about how we could use it as a source
okay
so so we're taking this primary source
and we're turning it into a secondary
source right so
say that
you are sitting down to
write an essay about the great
depression um and you've got to say all
right now how can i use franklin delano
roosevelt's inaugural address to make my
point in my essay
so let's say step 5
would say synthesize perhaps
it's my big word
as
a tool for your own argument
so i would say that this speech
is the frame that roosevelt is putting
on the depression this is how he is
creating the narrative that he wants
americans to adopt
yeah he is identifying the crisis and
this is how he wants people to see it
yeah so this might be a great primary
source
to tell you about
roosevelt's strategy or his
communication strategy what might it not
be a very good primary source to help
you make an argument for um it probably
wouldn't be a very good primary source
for um the republican legislative
response you know you might want to go
with uh senator reid smoot of utah for
something like that
right um and it's probably not a great
source for really diving into the
specifics of the new deal right i mean
he doesn't say anything about the
civilian conservation corps he doesn't
say anything about the national recovery
administration this is not the the nuts
and bolts of the new deal it's the grand
idea behind it right he's trying to sell
the new deal right so it's i think a
really powerful primary source for
understanding
the impetus behind the new deal but not
the programs sweet all right well thank
you for bringing your sweet grammarian
skills to the table as we look at
roosevelt's speech my pleasure thank you
for bringing your sweet historian skills
to the table kim and david out scholarly
high five